hi Matt Welch here with nick gillespie
on ask a libertarian day two points Oh
in honor of the paperback publication of
the Declaration of Independence with
atty how libertarian politics can fix
what's wrong with America the next
question comes from Jordan McGillis an
intern at the American Enterprise
Institute he asks drone strikes in Yemen
yay or nay Nick I you know there's a lot
packed into that drone strikes i'm not
against drone usage on against drone
usage that is done indiscriminately and
extra legally whether it's attacking and
killing American citizens without due
process or going into foreign countries
we do have a choice that is being
foisted on us by technology really about
warfare are we going to be doing boots
on the ground or we're going to be doing
unmanned drones from the sky it's
probably going to be a mix of both the
most important thing is that technology
changes the way war is waged but we need
to make make sure that we have the
political will and the political
institutions in place to wage war rarely
and legally whenever necessary i
remember in America where it was
considered de classe to randomly
assassinate foreign citizens let alone
our own citizens and i am very creeped
out by the fact that we seem to have
gotten away from that to the point where
even sort of liberal institutions are
celebrating the fact that President
Barack Obama is sitting around with his
sort of do not kill list winner Peace
Prize winner of Barack Obama's has his
little kill list that he uses his own
internal due process I think that that's
kind of broadly terrifying and something
that so we should locate relocate our
sense of outrage about we'll be back all
day